serves as a sort of private national
security advisor and Secretary of State
to about 30 major corporations around
the world such as American Express
freeport-mcmoran minerals trace
Manhattan Bank Volvo companies like that
and for each of them they pay about
$250,000 a year retainer plus $100,000
per month for a project fee if there's a
special project they want either dr.
Kissinger or the two or three associates
main associates he has in the firm to do
for them plus dr. Kissinger makes money
as a on boards of directors he makes
money for speaking fees he charges up to
thirty five thousand dollars a speech
and so it all adds up to quite a
lucrative post government work two of
the people that used to be in Kissinger
associates Brent Scowcroft and Larry
Eagleburger are at the prime positions
and foreign policy and the Bush
administration is there any kind of a
back and forth between all those people
now well he's still in touch with
Scowcroft and Eagleburger and they're
both still supporters of Kissinger and
there the interesting thing is their
ideology they're sort of realism their
notions of balance of power their rail
politique that you see in both Lawrence
Eagleburger the current acting Secretary
of State and Brent Scowcroft the
national security adviser but they don't
they not only worked with Kissinger in
Kissinger associates but they go way
back Lawrence Eagleburger
was Kissinger his right-hand man his
personal aide in 1969 when Kissinger
first became national security adviser
for President Nixon and like Weiser
Brent Scowcroft became the deputy
national security adviser in 1972 or 73
so they go way back with Kissinger and
they share his philosophy of the world
which is one of understanding balances
of power realizing that power rather
than sentiment or morality or human
rights determines the way the world
works and an understanding that America
has certain interests and you have to
pursue those interests in the world
sometimes with a cold and calculating
sense of realism Ross Perot has a little
book out that's number one the
bestsellers list to the paperback in new
york times and one of the proposals he
makes in there is that no one working in
government or certainly in the white
house should ever have contact with
foreign government
once they've left government he says
this is bankrupt our system what would
happen to Henry Kissinger if he wasn't
allowed well technically he wouldn't be
in too much trouble
he does not lobby on behalf of foreign
governments if you look at the spectrum
of influence peddling
in Washington it's not a very honorable
tradition but it's an old tradition in
Washington on the one hand one into the
spectrum you got Mike Deaver say who the
minute he leaves government pretty much
cashiers then known as connections as
quickly as possible and ends up in legal
trouble for it on the other end of the
spectrum you have such venerable
statesman is uh even Clark Clifford or
you know people like that who make
influence-peddling seem like an
honorable thing Kissinger is somewhere
in the middle and I say that because he
did not Lobby the US government for four
or five years until after he left office
still he does not do any direct lobbying
with the State Department or the
executive branch he's not really a
lobbyist thirdly he does not represent
foreign governments or any government
entity what he does is he represents
corporations he serves as an adviser and
a strategic adviser to them
he doesn't lobby for them in front of
the US government but he helps them get
contacts overseas understand foreign
governments understand what investments
they might want to make an Indonesia who
they need to talk to that sort of thing
so I think under the Ross Perot I
haven't I'm not sure of all Ross Perot's
rules that he would set up Kissinger
would squeak by I do think that it does
present some conflicts of interest when
a guy goes from government to out of
government and appears to be cashing in
on the connections he made for that
matter in kissinger's case somebody
serves as a commentator who is paid by
was paid by ABC and then NBC is a
commentator now on the board of CBS
appears on CBS writes a newspaper column
when he's writing say a newspaper column
or appearing on the news saying we
shouldn't impose sanctions on China
after the Tiananmen Square massacre it
would have helped if he would have said
and by the way I represent our Co which
is doing an oil and gas exploration
business in China
I represent HJ Heinz which is trying to
open a baby food factory in China I've
formed a group called China ventures
with coca-cola which is another client
and a few other clients that are looking
to do ventures in China and he could say
and I think he'd be right to say be
truthful if he said my opinions about
China aren't influenced because I have
these clients there as Winston Lord one
of his great supporters and aides said
and I'm sure Kissinger didn't like the
way phrased it but it's true said Henry
Kissinger does not need a penny of
financial interest in order to support
repressive dictatorships around the
world he does it naturally so I think he
probably would have felt the same way
about China if he didn't have these
interests but you get into an appearance
of a conflict there when you're going in
and out of government in and out of
commentary in and out of working for
private corporations it would help to be
a little bit more open than he is and a
little bit more what the right that he
is about what his various interests are
if we wanted to hire him how much would
it cost us let's say we had a little
company's bad no I mean how the two lay
oh we had a little joint clearly a lot
vote if we had a if we had a normal
corporation he would charge about two
hundred fifty thousand dollars just to
be on retainer for that we would only
get three or four briefings a year in
which he and one of his assistants came
and said okay the brian lamb walter
isaacson corporation wants to open a
copper mine in indonesia here's a
briefing on what's happening in the
South Pacific and in Asia and what's
happening in Indonesia the trends you
should worry about that sort of thing
now if we decide it well we need a
mineral concession in Indonesia the way
freeport-mcmoran did a few years ago and
we said to him could you come help us
set that up
he'd say sure I know the people in
Indonesia and he would fly with us
perhaps if we you know were able to talk
him into it like he did for the chairman
of freeport-mcmoran you fly into
Indonesia and he would introduce the
corporate leaders to the finance
minister the Prime Minister and other
important figures in Indonesia and for
that we'd pay about a hundred thousand
dollars per month of his time extra and
when he does this what goes along with
it in other words you said that when he
got out of government that one of the
first things he did was set up a
security unit of five people well I mean
what goes along with it is first of all
the name Henry Kissinger if you're a
company like ours say
company that you and I have formed and
we're not very well known in Morocco or
in Malaysia or Indonesia Singapore if we
have Henry Kissinger acting as our
consultant we get we get entree into the
top levels of government also you get
the strategic insights I mean he is a
brilliant man I know that my book has
been interpreted as being critical of
him and he certainly thinks it's far too
critical of him but I hope I also
display or show put on display his
ability to understand linkages in
foreign policy for example how something
you do in China might affect the
relationships you have in Malaysia or
how dealings in the Middle East might
affect your ability to do similar
dealings in Eastern Europe what I meant
by going all is do you have to supply an
airplane for oh man that you have to
does he have his own security and does
he travel like he used to when he was
secretary you know he doesn't like to
give up the perks that he had when he
was Secretary of State there are certain
people who as soon as they leave office
they retire back into that
semi-obscurity that is a luxury of
people who've already been famous and
they get to go into restaurants
unnoticed
they fly commercial that sort of thing
Henry Kissinger does not like to fly
commercial he does not like to enter
restaurants unnoticed so among other
things if he's going to do something for
us in Indonesia he's going to want to
borrow the corporate jet he's going to
want to be flown around
he has three or four security guards at
all times which helps I mean not only
does he have to worry about his own
security somewhat but anybody who enters
a meeting with three security guards two
preceding him and one coming after sort
of enters with a bit of a splash you
notice that Henry Kissinger has arrived
and in Manhattan it means you don't have
to wait at the bar for a table at a
fancy restaurant if your security guards
are coming in with you so he likes to
travel with all the pomp and
circumstance that is befitting a
Secretary of State and I think that adds
to his aura I mean one thing people ask
me when we talk about Kissinger is why
is it 15 years after he left office he's
still a larger-than-life personality
he's still somebody who's on all the
talk shows and he's on McNiel era
or when he enters a restaurant or when
he speaks he still commands a great awe
as well as animosity I mean he arouses
strong emotions unlike say Cyrus Vance
or Edmund muskie or you know other
people have been Secretary of State and
I think the reason is he works at it he
works at keeping his celebrity aura at
keeping his image high and that comes
with flying around with retainers and
security guards and being tightly
scheduled and making sure you're on TV
all the time so I think he tends to a
celebrity in this media age by the way
you know you look at c-span and networks
like this that has sort of created a new
media age he has learned one of the true
secrets of the media age because all of
us knew that if you're powerful it
translates into celebrity what he
realizes it works the other way if you
keep your celebrity or if you're a
celebrity it translates into power
because people are more interested in
what you say if your celebrity you can
command a higher speaking fee you can
command a higher consulting fee and when
you arrive in Indonesia or India or
Egypt or Morocco it's more likely that
the Prime Minister of the king is going
to want to call you in and have you in
for lunch if you're a big celebrity so I
think that was a secret he understood
about the media age how irritated is he
about this book well he's upset about
the portrayal of his personality the
fact that his methods were secretive
that he had a reputation for being
duplicitous as a Secretary of State and
these all come from the tales in the
book I think that he's very upset about
that I assume he's got too upset about
the fact that that he's not too upset
about the way up his own his foreign
policy because I think his foreign
policy especially in the Middle East
they talked with the Soviet Union the
opening to China were all brilliant
moves had helped establish America's
role in the world after Vietnam so he's
not upset I don't think with the policy
in the book one of his good lines if I
may paraphrase it is when asked about
the book he says well I hate the book
but I like the title by the way there
was another book called Kissinger yes
Marvin Kalb and Bernard Kalb did a book
in 1973 that was before Watergate and
before Nixon resigned
and so it came out kind of early this
was about 20 years ago and it's a
favorable look a sympathetic book to
Kissinger but also a very good book one
that's a very thoughtful book how long
did you work on this about seven years
getting back to whether he likes or not
he he did get very mad at William Hyland
as you may have heard Bill Hyland was
one of his longtime aides
a very close friend and supporter of
Kissinger and Highland's retiring now is
added to a Foreign Affairs by the way
this is Anwar Sadat not bill Han Yeah
right but anyway when Highlands
retirement party Kissinger was supposed
to be the speaker a week ago and when
Hyland gave the book a good review like
isn't revived for a good review in
foreign affairs Kissinger backed out and
got very angry at him so I think he's
angry about the book but partly if I may
say so I think if he read it carefully
and if you want quite so thin-skinned
and he certainly admits to being thin
skinned I mean he's notoriously so and
jokes about it ah he would realize that
the book is unbalanced favorable to much
of his foreign policy but at the moment
I think he's pretty angry about the book
when you decided to do this seven years
ago how did you go about it well first
of all I done a book with a friend of
mine called the wise man which brought
us up to the Vietnam period that was
about an earlier group of statesmen Dean
Acheson Averell Harriman and that crowd
so I decided I wanted to take it into
the Vietnam period and I wanted to use
Kissinger as the most complex brilliant
devious interesting intriguing character
we had through which you could see
Vietnam they taunt in that period no
foreign policy so I wrote him a note dr.
Kissinger had written some nice things
about the Wiseman I wrote him a note
saying I'd like to I'm about to embark
on a biography of you and he expressed
no real enthusiasm he said go ahead if
you want and I'm not sure I'll cooperate
but I knew that I couldn't let him have
the right to determine whether or not I
did the book or let it be an authorized
book where he had some control over so I
embarked and just went ahead and started
doing the book I interviewed a lot of
his friends interviewed his family
members began gathering papers
documents interviewed people were in
government with him and after a while he
became more and more willing I could
sense to talk
it is a subject and they say that's
quite interesting to Henry Kissinger
that's Henry Kissinger and so after a
while it became easy to get interviews
with him in fact he was quite eager to
talk because he loves to explain his
side of the story he likes to try to
convert his critics he likes to try to
woo both adversaries and allies to charm
and he loves talking about and
justifying what he did in government so
by the time I really got rolling on the
book I was able to talk with him I guess
close to 2,000 times and even sometimes
late at night I'd get a phone call
because he would hear that I've
interviewed I think it started when I
interviewed author Schlesinger about
whether or not tenure got whether
Kissinger got tenure at Harvard right
away why he was delayed a bit for tenure
I got a call from dr. Kissinger at one
point so saying Arthur Schlessinger does
not understand the tenure system at
Harvard I was not seeking tenure that
year and so he but you know he would
find out what what avenues I was
pursuing and often give me a call to set
me straight how old is he uh Kissinger
turned 70 in May and how active is he
today very active he scheduled months
and months in advance he has that that
sort of bustling air of impatient that
impatience that very important people
have around them his if you you know
he's scheduled hour by hour you know
through the next couple of months he's
always too tightly scheduled and he's
always dashing around from a business
meeting to some social function to some
gala party to some visit to some Foreign
Minister travel plans and so he's very
very active and no sign of slowing down
you list everybody that you interviewed
150 interviews and the names go all the
way from benazir bhutto to Jill st. John
yes Richard Nixon to Nguyen been to of
all those 150 and it's listed in the
back will show the audience what it
looks like who do you remember the most
Oh interviewing Richard Nixon was the
most interesting bit of it I had a
couple of informal sessions with Richard
Nixon before he granted me a
full-fledged interview what does that
mean informal well I went over to his
office or to his house in New Jersey
we'd sit around talking it would not
really be on the record at one point he
was excerpting his own memoirs and I was
working on that a little bit another
point was just a dinner where he was
talking and you could tell this
ambivalence he felt - its Kissinger I
mean he's a man who admires kissinger's
mind enormous Lee but is very wary of
Kissinger's personality and very jealous
of the acclaim Henry Kissinger got for
things that Nixon feels was should you
know the credit should go to Nixon and
so he would he would all of his
sentences Nixon sentences about
Kissinger would have spin on them if you
know what I mean he would say well I'm
not one to say that Henry Kissinger is
paranoid but and some people do of
course say he's paranoid there's Nixon
talking but and then he would go on to
tell some tale about Kissinger doing
something of Kissinger losing his temper
but he was always admiring of Kissinger
is mine
and when I did my formal interview I was
there and he said do you tape your
interviews I said no I take shorthand
pretty rapidly and it's easier for me
than taping they said he pulls out a
little micro cassette tape record he
says I hope you don't mind but as you
know I like to tape things I thought he
was kind of joking because the White
House tapes would got him in trouble but
he puts a little tape recorder there and
wants to tape the interview but half an
hour into it the tape gets kind of ill
runs out and he's trying to turn it over
and it gets stuck he's kind of all
thumbs with this little micro cassette
and finally says well I was never very
good at taping things I was you know so
I looked up and started to smile I think
he was making a joke but he seemed
serious about it he said but he was a
very I shouldn't make fun of the present
present Nixon very interesting guy very
sharp very good memory of exactly the
balances of power they created why they
did things and and although it was
exciting to spend time with Richard
Nixon the most important thing was truly
trying to understand the basis for this
triangular diplomacy between the Soviet
Union you know they talked with the
Soviet Union on one hand opening to
China playing the - off against each
other
seeing how that would affect Vietnam if
you play China off against the Soviet
Union and how America could retain a
role in the world so to hear him talk
about that was a very interesting I know
if you notice it but there are very few
pictures of mr. Kissinger and mr. Nixon
together in here
oh really there are a lot there there
exist many such pictures I think there's
one of them there in the executive
office building hideaway if there is
that but you know there's none of those
type up-close shots of him well in the
executive they used to sit in that room
and that's a hideaway office across the
street from the White House in the
executive office building and that's a
very typical scene there because Nixon
would sit there with his feet propped up
and he take a yellow legal pad and make
little notes and he would spend hours
just ruminating about the world and one
of Nixon's strengths as well as his
weaknesses was that he would love to
circle around a subject for hours and
take different angles on it and of
course that was bugged that room and the
White House tapes caught him in that
room many times I guess he forgot the
tape drawn but it was in that room where
he was ruminating about what to do about
the White House burglars at one point
not with Kissinger but that's what got
him in trouble because he said well we
could pay them hush money but that would
be wrong remember that scene
well that was typical of Nixon to sort
of look at it from this angle look at it
from that angle and what Kissinger would
have to do is hear Nixon talk about all
the different angles of foreign policy
they could do and figure out which would
be the most sensible to pursue because
Nixon would almost throw all these ideas
up into the air so they would sit in
that room for hours just sort of
figuring out what would happen what
would China do if we did this with the
Soviet Union
how would the North Vietnamese react or
how would Moscow reactor we started
bombing Hanoi right before the summit in
Moscow and you know they would they
would they would sort of co-conspirators
as they sat there in that room and
figured out foreign policy also very
secretive as I sat in that room they cut
out the State Department they cut out
the Defense Department from all their
deliberations and if you look at the
opening to China was done without the
State Department even knowing it was
Kissinger secret trip if you look at the
Paris peace talks on Vietnam Kissinger
was handling those secretly behind the
backs of the State Department that was
conducting the real negotiations
or the official negotiations State
Department didn't even know that
Kissinger was doing this likewise with
the arms control talks with the Soviet
Union and likewise with the secret
bombing of Cambodia so you'd have Nixon
and Kissinger sit in the office there
and make all of these plans and keep
them keep the rest of the government and
dark you leave us with the impression in
the book that you may have the fullest
account written of that famous scene
first written in the Woodward and others
final days in all days book yeah when
supposedly mr. Kissinger mr. Nixon got
down and he's in parade and all that how
did you put that thing together well
there are only two major participants in
that scene dr. Kissinger and President
Nixon and both are uncomfortable talking
about it but I raised the issue and went
through the scenarios and got there
virgins to the extent that they were
willing to talk but one interesting
thing about that scene and Woodward and
Bernstein got it basically right that
struck me as I was doing the research is
how it leaked out and what happened was
after Nixon and Kissinger have talked
for about an hour in the Lincoln sitting
room and Nixon's going to resign the
presidency the next day and Nixon asked
Kissinger Danneel down and pray with him
and they do and they pray and Nixon
cries and Kissinger tells him that he'll
be remembered better by history than he
is by contemporaries well what happened
is drenched with sweat his search of so
kissing group goes back to his office in
the West Wing of the White House and
they are waiting for him we've just
talked about these two men Brent
Scowcroft and Lawrence Eagleburger two
of his closest aides and they're waiting
for they know that Kissinger has been
summoned over to the Executive Mansion
and they're waiting for him to get back
to the office in the West Wing so he
gets back and starts to retell the tale
and then the private phone line from the
president rings on Kissinger x' phone
now Kissinger somewhat secretly was
taping every phone conversation that
came into his office and overnight a
battery of transcribers would come in
and transcribe those phone conversations
and he kept records it was also a dead
key so somebody else in the office if he
wanted them to could pick up the phone
and listen in and you wouldn't hear the
click because it was just
phone you can listen in on and didn't
make any noise so the phone rings
unbeknownst or they weren't thinking
about it but automatically the tape
machines go on and Eagleburger picks up
the dead key and listens in and Nixon
the dead key is where you pick up an
extension phone and you can listen in on
the conversation without making a sound
it doesn't click so it allow it was just
really an extension phone that allowed
Eagleburger listen in any and Nixon says
to Kissinger please don't tell them what
just happened don't tell them I was weak
don't tell them I cried and Kissinger
says if I ever speak of this scene I
will speak of it in terms of respect
which by the way Kissinger does speak of
Nixon in terms of respect about this
scene so Eagleburger his and then the
next morning Scowcroft comes in and
there the tape recordings of this whole
conversation as well as a transcript of
them and I interviewed general Scowcroft
about this and he said that on
kissinger's authority he destroyed those
tapes and got rid of those transcripts
so Eagleburger Scowcroft Kissinger and
Nixon all sort of knew about this scene
and that's at least how I tried to piece
it together for the book he asked you
about connections and networking and all
that basically right here where you're
sitting we take calls and have taken
calls since 1980 and a day or let's say
a week or two can't go by without
somebody calling up about the conspiracy
theories of foreign policy in this
country and all the connections so as
you started talking about these
different institutions I wrote them down
kept pulling them out of the book and I
want to ask you about the connections
Council on Foreign Relations what does
that have to do with Henry Kissinger
well Kissinger is whenever you have the
people call in and talk about conspiracy
theories or whatever and I see it when I
used to be on the campaign trail you get
these leaflets and they all have arrows
and exclamation points and the
connections between various institutions
and Henry Kissinger and Nelson
Rockefeller and David Rockefeller are
always sort of at the center of it the
Council on Foreign Relations is really
just a discussion group and Club in New
York City founded about 70 75 years ago
to discuss foreign affairs it's largely
funded by
the old boy establishment network of the
foreign-policy
elite in the East Coast uh partly John
McCloy and the Rockefellers and that
sort of thing it's not an insidious
institution it's a perfectly respectable
place I guess it's only drawback is it's
occasionally quite boring if people
drone on and on but it's not some
conspiracy or the heart of some
conspiracy to control the world
what it is is internationalist foreign
policy establishment a lot of bankers so
if you distrust the East Coast foreign
policy establishment and international
banking you would distrust the Council
on Foreign Relations but it's not part
of an evil conspiracy Henry Kissinger
got his start there to some extent he
was a graduate student at Harvard about
to become an assistant professor at
Harvard he takes some time off goes to
the Council on Foreign Relations to run
one of their study groups the study
group is on nuclear weapons and foreign
policy David Rockefeller a lot of other
people are involved he writes a book on
it nuclear weapons of foreign policy
that's published by the Council on
Foreign Relations becomes a best-seller
it helps redefine our thinking about
nuclear weapons and how they affect the
conduct of foreign policy after that he
becomes associated with the Rockefellers
and works for Nelson Rockefeller right
after working at the Council on one of
Nelson Rockefellers critical choice
series where you know Rockefeller would
gather thinkers to think about you know
the choices facing America so he became
connected to Nelson Rockefeller and to
the council and through them I guess the
next group you might mention would be
the trilateral commission right first
are you remember the council firm yes
I've been a member I am a member of the
Council and how does someone like you
become a member oh they they picked some
young people do I was I worked at Time
magazine a cover foreign policy they
start off by giving term memberships to
younger people and then eventually I was
elected a member
I think this membership of the council
spans a huge spectrum that people in all
sides of the spectrum they're young as
well as old I think the one connective
tissue that may say so is it is sort of
an internationalist foreign policy
establishment body is there one thing
that everybody that comes together
they're usually believes in
no I mean I'm not very favorable to
Henry Kissinger but he's a member I'm a
member
I don't think I guess I've seen them
there once in my life it's thousands of
members and you go to a particular
evening or particularly large where
they're having you know the Japanese
foreign minister be a speaker and maybe
a hundred people will go out of the
thousands of people who are members so
you don't really know it's not like a
club in which you know most of the other
members and all right so there's no
connective tissue it's not like you all
have to subscribe
everybody has to subscribe to a certain
theory of government how do you get
selected for it they have a they liked
about I don't have anything like I'm not
I'm not very good at I'm not that
closely involved with the council and
although I'll defend the council I'm not
I'm not on the membership committees or
the board but I think there's a
membership committee that elects a
couple of dozen people a year you get
nominated by other people and anybody
who deals in foreign affairs can be a
member it's no there's no exclusion no
litmus test of philosophy it's not
liberal or conservative or Republican or
Democrat and if you put up for
membership I think the only real
criteria is have you had any involvement
either as a businessman a lawyer or
journalist in deal or a government
official or an academic and dealing with
foreign affairs since I was a journalist
I dealt in foreign affairs some and you
know I mean I know George Bush was a
member and he felt he had to resign
because so many people raises a
criticism but I think he goes from you
know William Buckley to Daniel Ellsberg
it will probably all been members of the
council trilateral commission trilateral
commission is far more elite and and
harder to get into my definition of a
lead and hard to get into is that nobody
would ever invite me to be in it it's
people who are it's called trilateral
because their interests in Japan
Europe in the United States the
relationship between the three major
economic powers also somewhat funded and
started by the Rockefellers were large
contributors to help start this thing
it's mainly for international
businessmen and people who deal in
Japanese European and American relations
and
it doesn't have a particular class or
anything or some house where people go
but they have meetings I don't know I
think maybe two or three times a year
I'm not particularly sure and the
Bilderberg Group
yeah that's Kissinger was very involved
in the Bilderberg Group and as I say
it's not something that I've ever been
asked to join and so I don't have any
I'd write about it in the book and what
I know about is what people were members
have told me it first met in the hotel
Bilderberg I think in Holland about 30
40 years ago George ball was one of the
founders he was a great international
lawyer and diplomat the United States
and there were two European founders and
it's there to promote good European
American relations and especially for
the East Coast foreign policy
establishment types including some who
in the Council on Foreign Relations the
Bilderberg Group serves as a way to form
connections with similar people in
Europe and I think they meet at least
once a year yeah the last meeting was a
year or so ago on Long Island as a
matter of fact it's not usually in the
United States but last year it was and
it's a group of people from all over
Europe in the United States who come
together to discuss foreign affairs the
Bohemian Club Bohemian Grove that's more
of a social organization it's a club in
California where people go mainly in the
summertime they have camps and they sort
of cots and sort of outdoor camp type
things were grown man usually wealthy
industrialists and others get together
for a week or so of discussions lectures
putting on skits singing and probably a
lot of drinking and just having a good
time
and it's a President Reagan President
Ford George Shultz Henry Kissinger a lot
of people have been members of the
Bohemian Grove how about the
Metropolitan Club here in Washington I
don't know let me thought that you write
you wrote that a lot of meetings were
held there and it seemed to weave in and
out of your book yeah it's a good
gentlemen's club for members of the
Washington establishment especially for
old-time Washingtonians not the people
who rotate in and out for one
administration but for example Joseph
Alsop and people like that who with a
distinguished
Washington establishment we're generally
members of the Metropolitan Club one of
your chapter heads has to do with
Georgetown in Washington why did you
write about Georgetown and Henry
Kissinger well Kissinger became our
first celebrity statesman our celebrity
diplomat and he realized that in order
to be popular in the Nixon
administration not popular with
President Nixon who hated this but be
popular with the press and all he had to
be on the Georgetown party circuit so he
loved going and he was the toast of the
town he was the most eagerly sought
dinner guest in Georgetown but all the
Georgetown social circuit including you
know Katharine Graham to Joseph Kraft
Joseph Alsop the Braden's that crowd he
was the toast of their dinner tables and
and it helped him form good
relationships with say the colonists
people you know newspaper columnist TV
commentators as well as the real opinion
makers because that as you know being
here in Washington is a way a lot of the
wheels aggrieved in Washington is that
people may want to leak a little
something about how a particular person
in government is not doing very well it
has some crazy theory and the way to do
it is to tell the tale at a dinner party
and within maybe as six hours it's
spread all over Washington Kissinger was
a master at going to the dinner parties
cultivating the commentators and getting
a good press as a result you write it
chosen here that you had interviews with
Susan Mary all sob you had an interview
with Polly Kraft Katherine Graham a lot
of these interviews have to do with the
stories of how Henry Kissinger used to
try to manipulate their husbands or I'll
try believe like Kevin Graham what did
tell the story about Joe Kraft and
writing something and he wasn't he tried
to call him oh yeah well Kraft wrote
Kraft was somewhat of a liberal
columnist and although he was a friend
of Kissinger he was one of the few
people understood an essential truth
about Henry Kissinger which is that the
way to get his attention was not to try
to curry favor with him but to criticize
some of his policies because Kissinger
would then try to engage and
want to convince you otherwise and he
almost had more respect for people who
stood up and challenged him
well Kraft wrote a column I think about
Cambodia and about how bad the Cambodia
policy was Kissinger was furious and I
craft off not giving him anymore
what better craft was in bed wife saying
I'm sorry I'm not going to wake him up
he doesn't want away copy we can talk
about in the morning Kissinger called
back in finally the doorbell rings and
there's Henry Kissinger standing on the
doorstep in Georgetown saying he has to
see Joseph Kraft
to convince him and Kraft comes down in
his robe and they sit up late into the
night with Kissinger trying to explain
Cambodia to him did you leave the
impression that he invented the
background the deep background the not
for attribution the well he was the one
who played that game quite a bit he
loved dealing with the press and most of
the time he would talk not for quotation
but words he wouldn't talk on the record
but instead of just talking off the
record which means the stuff can't be
used he was the one who perfected the
notion of having different grades such
as he would talk on background which
meant whatever he said could be used but
it couldn't be directly quoted to Henry
Kissinger and that's how the phrase a
senior administration official or senior
White House official was often used when
Kissinger said something and then he'd
sometimes talk on deep background which
meant nothing could be really quoted at
all but the reporter could use the
information but not attributed in any
way so he had all those rules every now
and then it would get too complicated
once he was talking on deep background
about how Nixon might cancel a summit
meeting with the Soviet Union if
something didn't happen he was pushing
the soviets to do something and even
consulted with nixon on this nixon was
outraged when this came out but worse he
had it was such a big piece of news the
washington post decided it couldn't just
keep it on deep background couldn't say
according to those familiar with the
administration's thinking the summit
might be cancelled they decided to go
ahead and say Henry Kissinger says this
so that caused a great bit of
hand-wringing and Kissinger quit giving
background briefings especially to the
post as a lot of discussion finally the
post was brought back
to the ranch and they started going to
the background briefings again instead
of keeping him on background but he was
the one who could I mean as one reporter
said he played the press like a fiddle
because he was so interesting he was so
expansive he was so great at explaining
foreign policy that reporters naturally
gravitated towards him as a source
throughout your book you define you used
the word obnoxious and arrogant and you
say that he mistreated secretaries and
you have a whole chapter on wiretaps and
how he wiretapped his friends and his
colleagues and all that it's all that
true yeah I'm quoting people I don't
think on my own accord I would ever call
that but they're people who tell the
tales and show he had an enormous temper
it was very thin-skinned and les Gelb
who's now columnist with the New York
Times but who was a student of
kissinger's at Harvard worked a little
bit with Kissinger in government when in
and out of government around the time
kissing it was he said that Kissinger
was a typical product of an
authoritarian background Kissinger being
from Nazi Germany he said he was he was
devious with his peers obsequious to his
superiors and domineering towards his
subordinates and that's the aspect of
Kissinger personality I found very
unattractive he was a it was always
playing people off against each other
denigrating people talking about people
behind their backs it wasn't necessarily
outright duplicitous saying one thing to
one side and one thing to the other side
another thing to the other side but he
came close he would allow one side to
believe the doves or the Liberals that
he agreed with them and then he go talk
to conservatives and Hawks he let them
feel that he agreed with that side so he
got a reputation for being duplicitous
why do people put up with him well he
was charming he was brilliant he was
powerful and a lot of people didn't they
got very mad at him he made a lot of
enemies he was the most venerated and
most respected secretary of state many
ways but he was also the most hated
secretary of state and if you read the
book everybody I talked to talked on the
record because I didn't want people to
denigrate Kissinger under the cloak of
anonymity so of all the hundred fifty
people you talked about they're all
cited by name footnote and stuff but he
didn't get away
that in fact somebody once said he was
not really that masterful of a liar
because he was mellow Mastiffs Opie
wouldn't have such a reputation for
being one he kept getting clawed at it
but you know you look at what James
Schlesinger says about the kissinger in
the book and he says that you know i
think one of his quotes was most people
when they lie look to shame but when
Henry Kissinger lives he does it as a
matter of his own nature because it's
like an hour best to him or helmets on
and felt who worked for Kissinger who
said you know Kissinger doesn't lie
because it's in his interest he lies
because it's in his nature so you know
he didn't get Kissinger did not get away
with it that much because even people
who sort of liked him even people who
worked with him even people who
respected his mind still were upset and
would talk on the record about his what
they considered to be his devious
personality you know said and I don't
know where it is that five people would
not allow you to quote them what did you
do with all that information yeah I did
out of the 150 got some odd people I
interviewed there were five who wanted
to stay off the record I did not use any
allegations they made they weren't that
important they were not major characters
in the book what happened was maybe 50
people talked to me on background or off
the record but I went back to all 50 of
them and said look everybody else is
talking on the record if you want to say
this about Kissinger enough time has
passed you should be able to say it on
the record you should be willing to come
right out and say it and as I say out of
those 50 people about 45 said well yes
you can use what I said and use me as a
source five said no and it wasn't really
necessary to use any allegations they
made or anonymous quotes they made I
used the information in other ways by
say going to other people and trying to
verify through people who would talk on
the record and one of the footnotes are
read that you've been at time I read the
footnotes that's really happen then at
Time magazine since 1978 I I joined time
in 1978 I had worked on Sunday Times of
London before then and also the Norland
state item time speaking of New Orleans
being my hometown New Orleans is home
yeah where did you go to school now I
went to Newman in New Orleans and then
Harvard and then
Oxford in England for graduate work can
you remember when you first got
interested in being a writer
oh I studied philosophy at Oxford and
when I finished I realized that there
was not much of a need for philosophers
in this world you couldn't hang out a
shingle and and sort of make a living as
a consulting philosopher I was
interested in journalism I was
interested in history and it seemed like
a good thing to do after I graduated I
as I say worked for The Sunday Times in
London which was a very interesting
paper and then finally for the paper in
New Orleans what your parents do my
parents are my father's an engineer and
an architect in New Orleans and my
mother was a real estate agent for what
Nikolas lemon from yes Nick I just spent
I spent a week with Nick just this past
week in New Orleans his parents and my
parents and his grandparents and my
parents have been friends for
generations and he's a he's one of the
truly great scholars to come out of New
Orleans his book is great who got you
interested in history I was asked this
question in New Orleans a week or so ago
and I mentioned my high school history
teacher because he was in the audience
so I guess since this is a nationwide
show I better talk about my high school
history teacher ah I was always
interested in American history in
particular Andrew Jackson all the way
through and American foreign policy ah
and I studied history at Harvard did
some of it at Oxford along with
philosophy and it's a good outlet when
you're interested about the world to
look back and say and not just history
but I mentioned personalities in history
as was Kissinger because he who went to
Harvard he wrote his undergraduate
thesis on Conte and then on matter Nick
and then he wrote about Bismarck he
wrote at Napoleon Lord castlereagh the
British Foreign Minister all these 19th
century statesmen and he was very very
interested and believed in the role that
personality plays in affecting history
because you know one great school of
historical thought in the past
generation has downplayed the role that
people and personalities play and played
up economic forces or other things
Kissinger was a true believer in the
role that personalities play in fact
during the Middle East shuttles he said
not quoted in the book
said you know when I was a professor I
thought great forces shaped history now
that I'm up close to it I see what a
difference personalities make and so I
was always interested in the
personalities of history kissinger being
the most the larger-than-life
personality you dedicate this book to
betsy who is worthy of her name
my mother died about six years ago and
the wise man was dedicated to her among
other people and her name was Betsy and
shortly about two and a half years ago
we had a daughter named Betsy named
after my mother and she's a great
daughter
and so she's worthy of her name because
she looks like acts like and has the
same intelligence and spunk that my
mother did in fact I remember you
devoted a whole paragraph to your
daughter well I had to she's a demanding
two-year-old like all two years olds I
think I paraphrased a P G Wodehouse and
I said I'd wanted to dedicate the book
to my daughter Betsy without whose
invaluable help it would have been
written in half the time because it
would she would sit there on my lap and
play with the keyboard while I typed and
you said you started the book seven
years ago at what point there in seven
years did you spend the most time on it
what was there well up until 1988 I was
working as the national editor at time
and that was the as you know the 88
campaign the Bush Dukakis campaign so
most of my energies and focus of my
attention was Time magazine in our
political coverage after that I took a
little bit of time off I've been doing
that period I was doing a lot of the
interviews because I love talking about
Kissinger and it's easy to do the
interview it's all you have to do is say
Henry Kissinger the most people he'll
tell you a lot of stories I mean you
just push the button but then after the
election I became just a writer at time
for a while so I had more time to pursue
Kissinger and then eventually I guess
during that period when c-span visited
Time magazine and broadcast our meetings
for better or worse I was on leave of
absence for six or eight months doing
the writing of the book I've got here
the New York Times Book Review by
Theodore Draper and this was September
the 6th the reason I hold it up is that
not only did you get the front cover of
the book review for Sunday but five full
pages almost were devoted to this review
if you ever seen one
big I think it's a long as they've ever
done and I guess I'm flattered although
I fear people who said to me
gee I spent all weekend reading that
book review now I don't have to buy the
book and I'd say no no that's not you
should read the book but I so you sort
of feel that but it's a very interesting
review Theodore Draper is a great
scholar as you know and interestingly
enough was Kissinger after he immigrated
to America from Germany from Bavaria he
joined the US Army the 84th Infantry
Division and went back to Germany as
part of the counterintelligence Corps of
that division during the occupation of
Germany right at the end of World War
two interestingly enough Theodor Draper
was also in that division and was a
historian of that division is it true
that the New York Times does not have
someone review a book of somebody they
know I guess oh I've never met theater
driver I mean I've never seen him what
do you think of the review oh I thought
it was a very interesting but it was
certainly very favorable so I liked that
part of it he comes at it like anybody
who's gonna write about a Kissinger
biography he has his own opinions on
Kissinger his own analysis that I found
interesting but that is really it's it's
him speaking for himself as well as
reviewing the book but I found that you
know he's of course has thought about
kissing very very critical of Kissinger
I think perhaps a little bit more I
think I think my book is balanced and
not quite as critical as Theodor Draper
is of Kissinger but I was a very
flattered that somebody of that stature
would write about the book for such a
you know for this longest review in the
New York Times you have any idea why
they devoted so much space to know I've
been I don't know who to ask I if I run
into uh you know Draper I'll ask him
Barth Healy writes a little sidebar on
you and he says to a reader who has just
finished the 893 pages of Kissinger the
author 40 years old sandy-haired
boyishly anxious about his image uh
seems to have seems to have taken on
some of his subjects characteristics I
was very eager to try to explain certain
things and you know you get into
it is like Kissin I'm Kissin I was a man
who when you ask him about things he's
convinced that you're not going to
understand them and that he's got to get
you to understand what he did in
Cambodia what he did in the Middle East
why he had to cut the State Department
out of certain things and he has sort of
that eager quality to make you
understand and I guess like any
biography biographer you concede some of
yourself in the person you're writing
about he ends it with a couple of senses
I want to ask you about mr. Isaacson's
own extensive records are in boxes in
his basement he does not expect anyone
ever to ask for them I don't know why I
said that he yes we're kissinger's
papers were and said the National
Archives has some of the official ones
the Library of Congress has the private
papers that sort of thing and to me it's
very important if you're going to do a
biography of this nature to go to the
documents the written records the
archives and also do the interviews
because you have to triangulate some of
the memos are misleading but of course
people's memories may be faulty so if
you have both the memos and the memories
you can put things together and so I
spent a lot of time tracking down
people's papers and tracking down not
only Kissinger's but people who work for
Kissinger who tend to have their papers
in their own basements or you know they
haven't done anything with the papers
yet but they've kept memos of
conversations they had with him too
Kissinger and so he just asked me where
I kept my papers and I said well I guess
they're still in my basement and he
asked me whether I was going to donate
them to some library and it never
occurred to me that his library would
ask for all my papers so I said I didn't
expect anybody to ask for them but
anybody want some you know be happy to
donate them anywhere you say you took
shorthand on all the notes did you use a
tape recorder anywhere I don't think I
used a tape recorder maybe occasionally
but it's far easier to do shorthand and
view if you tape record a five-hour
interview then you have to go back and
you have to spend 10 hours transcribing
it and then what you have is shorthand
notes oh you know but you spend a whole
extra day doing that also
to me the act of transcribing or the act
of taking notes taking shorthand writing
down what people say allows me to focus
a little bit better on what they're
saying and in some ways gives me a
little bit more time to formulate a
question because you can you know you
can use your notes as a shield and it's
a way and it also it's just a way to
keep an interview more professional I
find and it gives you a better written
record of it as opposed to thousands and
thousands of tapes you know somewhere
that you can never really find what you
need when you to go through playing tape
after tape to try to find what you want
where did you find when Ben - president
- the former president of South Vietnam
had gone into exile in England when I
was first starting this book and I
tracked him down there I really wanted
him to talk because he one of these
people was very deceived by Kissinger
Kissinger secretly negotiated the
Vietnamese peace treaty without fully
consulting with the president of South
Vietnam who was our ally there yeah I
knew he had strong feelings and he had
never talked about them so I tracked him
down and then he came over to Newton
center right outside of Boston
Massachusetts where he has some
relatives and I think he kept a pretty
secret where he was he would have still
somebody he could cause controversy or
there are people who fought in Vietnam
who have strong opinions about President
to you so I promised I wouldn't say
exactly where he was but at the times
when I was meeting with him it was
either in the city of Boston where he
would come in town to meet or nearby and
I think he was living or staying in near
Newton and Newton Center what's he like
now he's a very dignified person not
better in the least strong memories
feels that he was betrayed by the US and
Vietnam feels very strongly about
Vietnam now that now that the Cold War
is over it's time for a democratic with
government to return to Vietnam he feels
that more American force could have won
the war he also feels that America was
trying to deceive him in cut-and-run and
that we never had any intention of
winning the
or I think to some extent that's true
what I don't think he fully grasps is
that America could not win the war for
him South Vietnamese could have won the
war I mean if the war was going to be
won it had to be won by the South
Vietnamese perhaps with American help
certainly with American support but
you're never going to be able to win at
a bargaining table what your allies in
place can't win on the battlefield it's
a rule of that Bismarck understood
Medtronic understood and I'm sure every
other scholar of warfare understood and
if the South Vietnamese were not able to
hold their own against the North
Vietnamese on the battlefield or in the
hearts and minds of the people of South
Vietnam then there was no way the United
States or Kissinger could negotiate at
the bargaining table something that
couldn't be won on the battlefield of
all these hundred fifty interviews that
you had and your list here which one was
the hardest
which person was the hardest to find
yeah president to I guess and hardest to
convince to give me an interview was
Richard Nixon it was remarkably easy to
track most of these people down partly
because there's a network they've all
worked with each other and one would say
you got a you know if I talked to Melvin
Laird he'd say we have to talk to
so-and-so and I talked to James
Schlesinger who was Secretary of Defense
he tell you must talk to so-and-so I get
oh I guess the hardest ones now that I
think about it though with a childhood
friends for example there's a guy named
Menachem Leone probably in that list
there
Kissinger's best friend when they were
seven years old they sat on benches
mixers as each other alphabetically
Kissinger Leon in German yeah in the
Israelite rail school in Germany and
forth to Germany the town where they
were raised they studied the Torah
together and Menachem leon's father was
a almost a surrogate father and a way to
kiss and Joe just like often people have
with their best friend's father and he
was very important to talk to but when
he was a child he was not named Menachem
that's the name he took when he went to
Israel
his name was Heinz as was Henry
Kissinger they were both Heinz's and so
I knew that there was this person Heinz
Leon and many other people like that and
he lived in Jerusalem and I finally was
able to track him down his Menachem Leon
who is a through a professional Society
for this he works in a certain fact any
remember the profession I think to go
seem there no I did not see him in
Jerusalem I talked about the phone a bit
and then he came through like a lot of
people you know you'd see them when
they're traveling to New York or other
places likewise a lot of the childhood
friends are now in Chicago somewhere in
Washington Heights but the best way was
most people from most of the Jews from
first Germany when they escaped right
before the Nazi Holocaust came to
Washington Heights which is in Manhattan
the upper part of Manhattan and they all
settled within a four or five block area
Paula Kissinger Henry Kissinger's mother
still lives in the apartment there and
I'd go up there like she's about 93 and
I'd go up there and just sitting in the
park there would be people who would say
oh yes we knew Kissinger when he was a
young boy in Germany and they would
point out or give me the numbers of
various other people to call and they'd
say oh you have to call Walter
Oppenheimer who by the way is in that
picture next to uh if I can point to it
here that's Henry Kissinger in the army
that's his first wife and fleischer and
that's an flashes previous boyfriend who
was a friend of Kissinger's from the
Bavarian region of Germany Walter
epidemic I think I tracked him down in
Providence Rhode Island where he's
nailed jeweler if I remember correctly
but just hanging around in Washington
Heights I'd get leads on where various
people from that wave of immigration was
let me ask you and we're running out of
time after you finish this book seven
years working on thinking about and
probably thinking more longer than about
Henry Kissinger is this on this man on
balance was he good for the United
States I think that the foreign policy
he was able to develop a balanced and
opening towards the Soviet Union
balancing it off with China allowing
America to have a new diplomatic role in
the Middle East through his shuttles
help preserve America's role in the
world and its influence in the world
after Vietnam when
as you'll recall there was a great sense
of retreat after Vietnam almost the Neo
isolationism and he helped preserve our
influence in the world that was
important because it helped stand up to
the Soviet threat stand up to the spread
of communism and I think gets some of
the credit and who knows how historians
will apportion all of the credit for
letting the internal contradictions of
the Soviet system work themselves out
and allow communism to collapse however
why I think his legacy and the long run
was not as lasting as it could have been
and in many ways detrimental was that he
had to feel for power in this world but
he didn't have a feel for the strength
that comes from the openness and the
values of our system and if anything won
the Cold War it was an appreciation
around the world for American values for
individual rights for the openness of
our system all sorts of things at
Kissinger with his secretive diplomacy
did not fully appreciate so I think the
structures were masterful as I say at
the end of the book but in some ways
they were built on a foundation of
bricks without straw they tended to
crumble after a while because of the
backlash against they taunt the backlash
against a lot of what he did the
unwillingness to support the Vietnam
agreement largely because it was done
without a good feel for the openness and
values of our democratic institutions
this is the cover of the book
Kissinger a biography by Walter Isaacson
thank you very much hey thank you Brian
thanks a lot for having me